salut à tous bienvenue dans l'Ouest là
où le soleil pour vousler cipline qui
compte 800 licenci 10 clubs 10
disciplines olympiques une seule
pratiqué à la Réunion un centre régional
l'entraînement et pour nous en parler
Gabriel jeanalbert ta passion c'est quoi
Gabriel c'est la voile et ben c'est
parti après 25 ans de pratique Gabriel
est un incontournable de la discipline
champion du monde en 98 il est
aujourd'hui à l'animateur de la vie du
plus gros club de Lille plus de 200
bateaux 3 sections 1500 scolaires toute
l'année la BNM est une institution
en fait pour pouvoir aller sur l'eau on
propose différents types de bateaux qui
sont adaptés à la fois aux différentes
pratiques et aux différents publics
alors ça démarre de bateaux qui sont
tout petit un petit peu rectangulaire là
ça s'appelle des optimistes ça ce sont
des bateaux d'apprentissage pour les
enfants à partir de 7 ans jusqu'à 13 14
ans donc le laser c'est le bateau qui
est en train de préparer G on va
naviguer seul la voie est plus grande le
bateau est plus grand c'est adapté à des
gabarits à partir de 15 ans et jusqu'à
l'âge adulte et c'est aussi un bateau
qui est support de d'une de deux
épreuves olympiques femmes et hommes
après troisième type de bateau qu'on
propose c'est le catamaran donc ça
s'appelle catamaran puisqu'il y a deux
coqus le bateau est c'est un support qui
est très stable du fait de l'écartement
des deux coques c'est un bateau qui est
relativement léger avec une voile
importante même deux sur certains ce qui
permet d'aller encore un peu plus vite
que ce que vont faire les bateaux à une
seule
coque une demi-heure plus tard et un
petit briefing et c'est parti dans la
zone d'évitage là où il y a
l'échauffement des bateaux avant la
pleain mer vous allez voir ces
différents passionnés avec différents
objectifs en tout cas c'est le temps de
la
casquette
parce que c'est un support beaucoup plus
fun qui part beaucoup plus vite on a
beaucoup plus de sensation et c'est
super de naviguer dans ces position de
de
vitessesivrement
c'est une la sensation de vitesse et la
sensation de pouvoir agir soi-même sur
les différents paramètres qui vont te
permett d'aller plus ou moins vite et la
sensation aussi de d'être stratège qu de
de choisir ta
direction poisson
vol gros
VAG
Z